j'ai un monstre à venir vous présenter
aujourd'hui c'est cette bête là c'est le
Asus ROG Strix car 16 pouces version
2023 nouvelle bête calme alors la
référence c'est le jeu
634 gardez-moi ce truc là belle bête
beau monstre qui est un ordinateur
gaming absolument incroyable alors qu'il
sera pas là pour toutes les bourses je
vais vous lire tout de suite s'il est
quand même relativement cher et je vous
donne le tarif à la fin de cette vidéo
si vous aimez les belles machines si
vous aimez la volupté si vous aimez les
courbes et bien vous allez apprécier
cette machine je vais vous la présenter
je vais tout vous dire vous allez savoir
ce qu'on peut retrouver des lettres de
tous les côtés bref la performance sous
le capot c'est Intel Core c'est de la
13e gêne je vais tout vous dire sur
cette machine dont je mange toujours le
nom j'ai ma fiche à côté c'est le Asus
ROG Strix scar 16 et ça c'est cool allez
on y va
on va commencer par le format c'est une
bête qui est quand même assez épaisse
assez grosse regardez-moi ce truc là
c'est quand même relativement épais il
fait ces 2,5 kg donc vous allez pas
fatalement l'emmener partout avec vous
c'est vrai qu'on se dirait c'est un PC
portable un PC portable de gaming c'est
un produit qu'on peut emmener partout
avec soi pour autant je suis pas
extrêmement convaincu parce que je
trouve quand même relativement lourd je
le trouve relativement épais alors on
peut l'emmener si vous partez en
vacances ou vous allez faire du
télétravail je ne sais où c'est clair
c'est facile mais c'est pas un truc
qu'on va glisser tout le temps dans un
sac à dos et emmener ce truc là c'est
quand même épais et c'est pas
nécessairement totalement adapté en plus
de ça si vous voulez prendre ce bloc de
Charles qui vous servira à faire des
haltères donc si vous voulez vous
muscler un petit peu mais vous pouvez
faire avec ça c'est quand même aussi
relativement costaud alors chargeur mais
évidemment secteur qui est très rapide
donc ça c'est cool on se parle ici quand
même de 330 watts on n'est pas là pour
déconner donc bon voilà on a un truc
quand même un petit peu fantasme donc en
termes de mobilité cette machine même si
c'est un PC portable de gaming on va pas
forcément l'emmener tout le temps
partout avec soi après en termes de
finition alors il y a vraiment un parti
pris qui est très élégant et très joli
ici Asus vous allez avoir toute cette
petite arête arrière qui servira au
niveau de la ventilation parce que ces
machines là il faut venir les refroidir
et je trouve ça assez joli en fait ça
donne vraiment une courbe qui est très
très particulière on est sur un châssis
totalement en plastique avec le logo qui
est là cette petite diago qui est très
jolie mais qui est pas vraiment diago
parfaite vous voyez comme on pourrait
l'avoir ici d'un angle à l'autre mais
qui vit un peu casser cette symétrie qui
est assez jolie à l'arrière de
l'extraction d'air bien évidemment il
faut venir ventiler sur le dessous il y
a aussi un parti pris qui est très joli
avec vous le voyez il y a écrit Rogue là
toute l'optimisation au niveau de la
ventilation également qui va être
surélevé là par des petits patins enfin
spécialement des patins en tout cas vous
avez ici je sais pas si on peut parler
patin sur un ordinateur portable donc il
est plutôt bien fait et totalement
optimisé pour la ventilation à l'avant
vous allez voir on a de la LED et de la
LED à l'avant il y a de la LED également
à l'arrière il y a de la connectique
alors on peut commencer par regarder la
connectique mais vous le voyez déjà ici
vous avez une très grosse grille qui va
servir avant qu'il est une fois de plus
là vous avez votre porte d'alimentation
du RJ45 du HDMI 2.1 vous avez deux USB C
qui vous serviront plus à venir le
recharger si vous voulez le chargeur en
usb-c vous pouvez le faire c'est du 3.2
power délivrer bien évidemment je vous
l'ai dit j'ai 5 également vous avez une
petite prise jack ici pour le micro et
pour le casque et de l'autre côté vous
avez deux USBA trois points 2 donc en
termes de connectique on a ce qu'il faut
alors on le voit qu'on est sur un PC de
gaming et pas un PC pour les créatifs
parce que vous n'avez pas de port SD
micro SD pour me dire brancher une carte
ici il y en a pas après est-ce que c'est
vraiment ce qu'on vient chercher ici je
ne suis pas convaincu lorsque vous
l'ouvrez et bien regardez il fait
apparaître un très beau clavier qui est
ici n'est pas un clavier mécanique mais
vous allez avoir toutes les touches qui
sont rétroéclairées c'est du rgbc
éclairage individuel donc là je vous ai
poussé la luminosité à fond je coupe
l'éclairage pour vous le voyez regardez
là vous voyez vraiment l'éclairage ici
avec toute la bande de LED que vous avez
à l'avant mais il y a également un
éclairage par l'arrière donc ça donne
une loup qui est très très particulier
qui est très sympa alors il y a
différents modes là j'ai un mode
arc-en-ciel voyez qui est assez marrant
je vais avoir le mode statique ça bouge
pas j'ai le mode pulsation ça va venir
pulser comme ça je vais avoir le mode
stroboscopique qui est aussi assez
marrant j'ai le cycle de couleur où ça
va venir changer et modifier les
couleurs et je me retrouve avec
l'arc-en-ciel ici vous voyez donc j'ai
le choix moi je vais le mettre en cycle
de couleur vous avez votre band LED qui
est posée juste au dessus là de la
grille de ventilation qui est assez
sympa vous avez effectivement le dos qui
va être éclairé ici avec le logo qui est
très cool vous avez une bandelette aussi
qui vient contourner sur le devant mais
légèrement aussi sur le côté comme ça ça
c'est très très chouette et puis bien
évidemment les touches qui sont au rétro
éclairées c'est du RGB c'est joli ça
marche bien on croyez dans l'univers du
gaming on a une très très belle machine
alors c'est avec l'éclairage là on le
voit un petit peu moins bien ça pète un
peu moins bien mais bon faut bien qu'on
voit un peu ce qu'on montre aussi en
vidéo donc ça c'est cool donc on a un
très joli design et en plus de ça si
vous venez regarder le petit point de
détails parce qu'il y a plein de détails
de tous les côtés ici vous allez avoir
aussi votre diagonale avec le logo qui
passe juste là et qu'on vient retrouver
de l'autre côté donc il vient vraiment
faire le tour de votre machine sans
oublier l'écriture au niveau de votre
trackpad vous avez ROG Strix car les
références et vous en avez également ici
au niveau du trackpad on est chez Asus
on est chez Rogue avec bien évidemment
la touche d'alimentation qui a cette
forme qui est très particulière et très
jolie plus tout le design que vous allez
venir retrouver ici on a une vision en
transparence qui est juste hyper
élégante sur toute la longueur donc
mais ici on va se concentrer sur le 16
pouces que je trouve déjà quand même
vachement bien en terme de qualité en
termes de confort de visionnage vous
avez une dalle qui est juste magnifique
et pour venir faire de grossesions de
gaming est-ce qu'il faut alors on pense
toujours grosse session gaming sur
l'ordinateur comme ça mais on va
également penser multimédia si vous
voulez venir regarder des films des
séries et compagnies on va pas forcément
venir l'acheter pour cet usage là parce
que ça serait quand même fou d'avoir une
config comme ça pour venir regarder des
films et des séries mais en plus des
sessions de gaming et de toute la
performance que vous avez à l'intérieur
vous avez un très bel écran en mini LED
pour venir consulter du contenu
multimédia et une fois de plus ça c'est
quand même vachement chouette alors je
vous parle de multimédia il y a un truc
que je tiens quand même un peu à pondéré
et qui est un peu en dessous ça va être
toute l'expérience au niveau des
haut-parleurs l'expérience audio on se
dirait effectivement sur un ordinateur
qui coûte quand même relativement cher
en une très bonne expérience audio et
ici j'ai pas forcément extrêmement
convaincu regardez je vais vous faire
écouter je vous emmène sur ma chaîne
youtube hop là on se met un petit play
et on écoute on va regarder je vais
mettre le son vraiment à fond
il y a un truc qui est quand même très
médium bon c'est assez large au niveau
de la spatialisation c'est pas dégueu
mais je reste vraiment pas convaincu par
la qualité audio ici et la qualité
sonore c'est vrai que j'ai tellement
pris une claque ces dernières années
avec les derniers MacBook Pro vous avez
une très belle spatialisation et le
spectre est très bon très large donc là
ça marche très bien au niveau des graves
au niveau des aiguilles des médiums ils
sont très jolis là ça reste quand même
beaucoup dans le médium et c'est un peu
dommage alors on nous dit effectivement
il y a de le biath mot sur toute
l'expérience bon ok on sent que c'est
large mais voyez ça manque vraiment
quelque chose et je reste un peu sur ma
faim là-dessus alors on se parle
vraiment ici d'une machine orientée
gaming avec de la performance soyons
clairs moi ici j'ai une version avec un
i neuf je suis sur une 13e génération en
Intel Core la référence exacte c'est la
13980 HX comme ça vous savez tout en
plus de ça j'ai une carte graphique j'ai
une Nvidia Geforce RTX 40 90 avec 16 Go
de mémoire graphique dédiée moi j'ai des
DR6 et là si on a config j'ai 32 giga de
ram en DDR 5 et je peux monter jusqu'à
64 Go de RAM donc en termes de
performance vous avez vraiment ce qui va
ici alors ce qui fait que cet ordinateur
il aussi bien orienté pour le gaming
mais si vous êtes gamer et vous faites
de la vidéo que vous êtes monteur aussi
vous avez une machine qui ira
parfaitement bien tout en sachant que en
stockage soit avoir 512 Go soit 1 Tera
soit 2 ttera ici en SSD PCI et un sujet
aussi super important sur l'ordinateur
portable comme ça gaming c'est
l'autonomie alors souvent l'autonomie
c'est pas le truc le plus fou c'est un
peu le parent pauvre et ici une fois de
plus l'autonomie elle est pas Dingo
Dingo vous avez beau avoir une batterie
de 90 W vous allez pas aller extrêmement
loin une fois de plus ça va dépendre des
modes dans lesquels vous allez être je
vous montre dans Armory creat vous allez
avoir différents modes là vous voyez je
suis en silencieux par défaut je peux
venir me mettre en performance si je
veux la voyez ça va tout de suite monter
ça va aller un peu plus loin en terme de
perte bien évidemment et une fois qu'il
est branché je peux me passer en mode
Turbo alors bien évidemment ça c'est
quand même très pratique ça me permet
d'aller beaucoup plus loin en expérience
de gaming le mode silencieux en terme de
gaming vous allez être un peu limité il
faut venir monter dans les tours bien
évidemment vous le branchez sur le
secteur et vous profiterez de la
meilleure expérience si vous restez en
mode performance et que vous le branchez
pas sur le secteur vous allez fatalement
avoir l'autonomie qui va descendre donc
ici vous attendez pas avoir une
autonomie folle folle et l'emmener
pendant des heures 8 9 10 heures à venir
jouer sur matrix clairement ça sera pas
ça ça va être bien en dessous ce que je
vous recommande quand même c'est dès que
vous en avez la possibilité et que vous
venez jouer et bien vous le branchez sur
le secteur sur quoi vous risquez
souffrir au niveau de l'autonomie et de
toute façon vous ne pourrez pas activer
le mode Turbo ce qu'on recherche ici
c'est le maximum de performance donc le
mode Turbo on en a besoin soyons clair
tout en sachant qu'ici vous avez 4
sorties pour venir extraire l'air que
vont venir évacuer vos ventilateurs et
en plus de ça que ce soit au niveau du
CPU du GPU vous avez une dissipation
thermique il savait que le métal liquide
thermal kizi conducto note extrême voilà
c'est très compliqué à lire et c'est sur
mon papier en fait la référence elle est
un peu habitable mais ce qui vous permet
d'avoir une très bonne dissipation
thermique au niveau de cette machine là
bien évidemment ça va dépendre si vous
le mettez en turbo extrême compagnie que
vous le mettez sur les genoux vous allez
le sentir mais est-ce qu'on vient jouer
avec un PC de gaming sur les pour moi la
réponse est clairement pourquoi et bien
parce que d'une ça va vous chauffer les
genoux et c'est pas bon et de deux ça
vient bloquer la dissipation thermique
avec vos genoux qui vont être posés là
donc vraiment ça on évite et on le fait
pas au niveau logiciel ça sera prise on
tourne sur un Windows 11 vous connaissez
Windows 11 on en a déjà parlé ça marche
bien ça c'est cool pas de surprise ici
je vous parlais de ce clavier tout à
l'heure que je trouve très très agréable
super confort à utiliser donc ici pas de
mauvaise surprise également le fait
d'avoir ces raccourcis sur le haut je
trouve ça bien vous pouvez bien switcher
très facilement au niveau des modes
notamment passer en mode performance ou
en mode silencieux ça c'est plutôt bien
également le mode aura pour venir
changer l'éclairage avec les LED ça
aussi c'est très très pratique et vous
l'avez directement comme ça donc ça je
trouve ça plutôt pas mal non plus vous
pouvez venir désactiver votre pavé
tactile si vous le souhaitez et puisque
je vous parle de ce pavé tactile je
trouve pas mal fichu alors c'est vrai
que je suis habitué au MacBook Pro avec
un très gros pavé tactile on pourrait se
dire qu'ici il y a juste pour aller un
peu plus loin et pousser un peu plus tes
limites pour venir écarter un peu plus
son pavé tactile en allant jusqu'ici
mais globalement comme il est là déjà je
trouve très pratique très réactif avec
un vrai clic qu'on vient retrouver ici
ou ici donc ça ça marche et comme on a
besoin de performance qu'on a besoin que
ça aille vite on a besoin de
connectivité très rapide alors on peut
soit se brancher 45 et c'est globalement
ce qui va le mieux mais si vous voulez
venir vous connecter en WiFi vous pouvez
vous connecter en wifi si ce puisqu'il a
du wifi si ce à l'intérieur il faut bien
évidemment que vous ayez une box wifi si
ce et l'idée derrière c'est d'avoir une
très bonne connexion internet pour cet
article un maximum alors cette bécane là
comme je l'ai ici comme elle vous est
présentée elle est dispo au tarif de
accrochez-vous c'est pas piqué des
hannetons
3899,99 alors bien évidemment si elle
vous intéresse je vous mets un lien
d'affiliation en bas dans la description
c'est une très belle machine soyons
clairs elle est destinée aux personnes
qui ont de l'argent qui veulent allouer
un certain budget à leur PC de gaming
bien évidemment qui ont la capacité de
mettre un petit peu moins de 4000 € sur
un PC de gaming mais qui veulent une
machine très exigeante alors attention
très exigeante elle est très belle
finition superbe écran beaucoup beaucoup
de performances l'autonomie c'est pas
forcément son point fort c'est pas
forcément un PC qu'on va emmener partout
avec soi de parles encombrement et de
par le poids que ce soit du PC ou du
bloc de charge bien évidemment mais si
vous voulez une machine très exigeante
avec aujourd'hui ce qui se fait de mieux
sur PC et bien le Asus ROG Strix scar 16
est une très jolie machine que je trouve
vraiment extrêmement chouette une fois
de plus je suis pas convaincu qu'on en
vende énormément deux par le tarifs qui
est quand même très élevé mais pour des
gamers invétérés qui veulent un PC
portable très exigeant ils auront réussi
de quoi répondre à leurs exigences et se
faire plaisir d'ailleurs vous je sais
pas si c'est votre cas dites moi ce que
vous en pensez dans les commentaires
est-ce que cette machine là pourrait
vous tenter est-ce qu'elle pourrait vous
plaire qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
toutes les finitions qu'est-ce que vous
pensez bien évidemment il y a de tous
ces éclairages LED qu'on va venir
retrouver un peu partout autour de cette
machine est-ce que ça vous botte ou pas
moi j'aime bien ça la type sans en faire
trop je trouve ça assez joli et si on
veut venir la poser on l'utilisant en PC
pour venir travailler dans un open space
et compagnie bien vous prévenir
désactiver les LED et les remettre
lorsque vous voulez jouer et avoir des
gros sessions de gaming voilà donc elle
est un peu passe-partout ça c'est quand
même pas mal même s'il reste quand même
très typé gaming c'est normal on est
chez Asus Rogue donc dites-moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas dans les
commentaires et puis on se retrouve
bientôt bien évidemment pour continuer à
parler tech on parlera un peu de PC
beaucoup d'autres choses et ça vous
allez voir c'est passionnant je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]